si le combat semble déséquilibré contre
son fils elias le duel contre sofia sa
fille semble plus compliquée pour linda
j'ai réussi à tenir et qui parce que je
suis plus costaud mais ils ont tenu
aussi long et ça me faire tomber une
fois je t'aime tu les avais pas une fois
et et tu m'as fait tomber une drogue
oui yazid et linda sont venus avec leurs
deux enfants pour passer une matinée à
l'urban jam de maurepas plusieurs
activités dunk free jump ou encore un
parcours ninja warriors un défi relevé
par sofia j'ai fait le parcours j'ai
fait l'élastique
j'ai fait les paliers de pastèques je
fais des celtes sur le trampoline
j'ai sauté au trampoline en plus c'était
le moyen de passer un moment en famille
avec les enfants nous à quatre cas c'est
ludique et c'est nouveau et surtout et
trampoline c'est un truc est super sympa
quoi et on n'a pas l'habitude d'en faire
c'est justement en constatant cette
demande qu aurélien guillot a ouvert ce
centre le 25 mars dernier
ancien trampolinistes du club des
clayes-sous-bois il a dû arrêter suite à
plusieurs blessures
aujourd'hui il vit sa passion autrement
quand le concept est arrivé il ya un peu
moins de deux ans maintenant en france
c'est vrai que je me suis tout de suite
intéressé et
voilà j'ai tout de suite cherché à
développer cette activité là j'ai déjà
une activité à côté que j'ai que j'ai
cédé pour pouvoir faire cette activité
là après ces efforts la famille boussaïd
peut rentrer à la maison avec des bons
souvenirs en hauteur